welcome back to another movie clips
review today we're discussing yet
another oscar-nominated documentary
twenty feet from stardom I'm Jas and I'm
Jimmy so 20 feet from stardom tells the
story of some of the most prolific
backup singers ever to have graced as a
recording studio it opens with Bruce
Springsteen talking about the walk to
the front and it relates where the film
gets its title that woods its twenty
feet from being the backup singer up to
the front of the stage we are in the
limelight and that walk that distance
even though it's it's so close but
you're soaked yet so far yeah and it
really the whole film kind of explores
what it means to be a backup singer
trying to get to that and spotlight even
one of the women she won a Grammy for
her first solo artist yeah performance
but right away she was shelved by the
label and she went back to doing backup
vocals and now she works for sting and I
apologize if I'm not doing justice to
these people by naming all of them it's
just so dumb there's a lot of names
there are holes your honor of names but
then every so often you meet like Ray
Charles comes on screen to talk about
you know the power of the back of
singers and yeah every one they are
archival yeah yeah I mean yeah but like
Stevie Wonder is another another big one
that has a big presence in the film Mick
Jagger has a presence in the film
staying has another
but the other so the other storyline for
me that was very interesting was and I
think this is with Darlene love four
years later she'd sort of left the
entertainment industry and she was
actually cleaning houses yet honey and
so she was at one clients place you know
just doing her business and a song came
on the radio and it was one of her songs
and she heard her voice and she just
like that was a real posmotret her life
she's like what am i doing I had this
talent why should I waste it and you
know she left that job it's been
pursuing it ever since yeah and besides
following Darlene love we also follow an
up-and-comer Judith Hill yeah who I mean
she worked under michael jackson she was
on section on the boys yes we might
remember her from there um and you know
it's still open ended you know her story
is still very much untold it's a
fantastic film I initially had my
reservations about saying it because it
didn't seem very interesting but having
seen it i can say that is absolutely
joyous and not to be missed i'd say
check it out it's actually the only
oscar-nominated film that you can't
catch on netflix right now but I mean
it's streaming on some other video on
demand services I also highly recommend
it and yet for movie clips this is jas
but I'm Jimmy thanks for watching